I'm just living the dream onna oh how I
wish this could last forever
all I've wanted things to stay the same
and you promised him they would but that
was one tough promise to keep onna
because everything changes eventually we
knew you were a hero Anna but you really
saved the day and frozen too if it
hadn't been for you the spirits would
still be enraged by your grandfather's
actions you kept on going when things
got rough and continued to do the next
right thing Elsa's lucky to have a
sister like you we loved every second of
frozen - it was funny emotional and
everything we thought it would be and
more but through all the glitz and
glamour we spotted some easy to miss
Easter eggs jokes and observations that
we're about to share with you but we
should warn you this video is jam-packed
with spoilers watch until the end to
find out what really happened to Elsa
after she froze and why she chose to
abdicate the throne
the spirits will do anything for peace
the frozen franchise just wouldn't be
the same without Olaf the adorable
snowman who likes warm hugs and long
walks on the beach we loved all the
humor he brought to the table so we
couldn't help but hold our breath when
Olaf got lost in the Enchanted Forest
only to be chased by the elemental
spirits without his help Anna finally
found out what caused the spirits to
form a mist around the forest and
threaten arendelle sanctity as it turns
out AG nars father was to blame for the
fight that broke out between the North
Aldred tribe and the arendelle soldiers
and since the spirits do not like
violence they chose to retaliate but if
the spirits hate violence that much why
were they hell-bent on harming poor
little Olaf he must have dodged dozens
of fatal blows throughout his adorable
solo when I'm older these spirits were
out to get Olaf and if it hadn't been
for his remarkable self rebuilding
skills
Olaf would have been lost for good the
Tarzan theory ever since the first
frozen film hit the big screen in 2013
fans have been convinced that Elsa and
Anna have a long-lost brother named
Tarzan who was born after King Agner and
Queen I do know washed up on a deserted
island the Tarzan Theory seemed so
plausible that it was even endorsed by
frozen co-director Chris buck but after
watching frozen two we can officially
say that this theory has been debunked
as it turns out else Anna honest parents
did indeed pass away when their ship
capsized in the Nordic sea elsa felt
responsible for her parents demise but
on I did her best to console her King
Agner and Queen I do know we're on a
quest to find out where Elsa's powers
came from and whether they could be used
to take down the fog so unlike popular
belief Agner and i Doudna were not on
their way to Rapunzel's wedding when
their ship went down do you still
believe in the Tarzan theory if so tell
us why in the comments the new Danish
author Kristoff can I borrow your wagon
and spend frozen to finally gave us some
insight on Elsa and on his mom Queen I
do now we knew that King Agner was the
descendent of arendelle royalty but a
Dunas past was a big question mark
thanks to the sequel we finally know
that I do not in the Enchanted Forest
where she was a proud man
of the north will draw a tribe a Doudna
chose to go against her people and save
the young prince of arendelle she
escaped through the fog just in time to
return Agner to his people and was
forced to live out the rest of her days
in arendelle do you remember the scene
where young Agner is reading a book
under a tree and she pops down to
inquire about what he's reading Agner
says he's reading a story by the new
Danish author and while the King's
answer is a direct reference to Hans
Christian Andersen the famous Danish
writer responsible for inspiring the
frozen franchise Hans Christian Andersen
was born in the 1800s which is when the
frozen movies take place did you catch
this reference tell us in the comments
Christoph's heritage Kristoff has always
been the odd one out meet my family hey
guys there rocks he talks to rocks about
his feelings and voices his reindeer
spends thoughts without ever hearing him
speak a word
Kristoff had always felt like a reject
until he found his fiery princess on it
but it wasn't until Kristoff met Ryder
that he found out that his love for Sven
was somewhat normal Ryder has a deep
connection with reindeers going as far
as to lend them his voice just like
Kristoff Ryder and Kristoff immediately
hit it off Ryder even helped Kristoff
propose to Anna in the total North
aldrin fashion so we were wondering did
Christoph's parents also belong to the
north old rut ride it's very possible
considering how similar they are and if
I dunno made it out of the forest before
the fog barrier came crashing down it is
possible that others did too whatever
the case may be
Kristoff definitely has found his first
human best friend in writer the parents
letter fans first came across old norse
language in the original frozen film
when king Agner flipped through a nordic
book to find out how to save his
daughter anna and in frozen - we once
again come across a series of strange
symbols in the letter on a found in her
parents ship fans were curious to find
out what the letter said however Elsa
and on 'add discarded the letter once
they read what their mother had written
at the top left of the page we don't
have the decipher text just yet but we
can't tell you what fans think this
letter is hinting at
according to some eagle-eyed fans this
letter sets up the events for frozen
three yes that's right some viewers are
convinced that a third and final
installment to the frozen franchise is
imminent if frozen 3 does happen what do
you think it'll be about before we
reveal what really happened to Elsa
after she froze solid we want to make
sure that you'll be the first to watch
our latest frozen videos so subscribe to
the things if you haven't already and be
sure to hit that notification valve if
you're watching on your phone go on
YouTube settings and turn on those
notifications now let's get back to
business
Elsa's powers the most exciting thing
about frozen 2 was finding out the truth
about Elsa's powers
we have always feared Elsa's powers were
too much for this world the people of
arendelle had always been scared of
magic which is why King Agner his father
chose to betray the North old red tribe
so it makes perfect sense that Agner
wanted to keep Elsa's powers a secret
especially since his people blamed magic
for what happened in the enchanted lands
but unlike the north old ro tribe Elsa
can wield her own ice magic instead of
borrowing it from the elemental spirits
in frozen 2 we find out that Elsa's
powers were a gift given by the spirits
as it turns out the spirits saw what I
do not did for Agner amongst the chaos
of the Kings betrayals and they approved
of her selfless deed so they rewarded
the couple's firstborn with the magical
spirit of the fifth element
so while Elsa spent her entire life
viewing her powers as a curse it turns
out they were a gift by by Anna and Olaf
Olaf is a happy-go-lucky snowman he's
filled with love and awe and happiness
but in frozen - Elsa did something that
made all I feel anger for the first time
she pushed on in Olaf away putting them
in an ice canoe and sending them as far
as the eye could see Elsa did this to
keep them safe but her hasty actions put
them in harm's way because of what Elsa
did on an olaf came this close to waking
up the stone giants and getting crushed
by them clearly the stone giants meant
business and would have done anything to
stop out all the light from the forest
so while Elsa was trying to protect her
sister
actions almost got her killed Anna is
not powerless whether Anna likes to
admit it or not she grew up in her
sister's shadow now only was also born
first making her the true heir of
arendelle but she also has magical
powers whereas Anna does not many of us
believe that Anna would discover powers
of her own in frozen to after all she
had all the makings of a wonderful fire
princess
but as Olaf so blatantly put it on ax is
powerless did you see the look on her
face when that word came out of Olaf's
mouth
she was totally stunned by his harshness
while Anna doesn't technically have
powers she isn't powerless and she's
proven that time and time again she
risked her own life to write her
grandfather's wrongs and she used every
ounce of her willpower to get the deed
done Elsa may have saved arendelle but
it was Anna who brought peace back to
her Kingdom Elsa isn't alive anymore
Elsa never wanted to be the queen of
arendelle she always felt different and
yearned for adventure grand pabbie
warned Don and Elsa might go too far and
that's exactly what she did honest edit
herself her sister gave her life to find
out the truth frozen fans are debating
whether or not Elsa is still alive after
all it wasn't like Elsa frozen time she
literally passed away which is why Olaf
faded from existence
Elsa unfreezes once Anna takes down the
bridge but some fans are convinced that
she's only alive in spirit
after Elsa unfreezes she completely
transforms her hair gets wider and so do
her clothes making her look a little
ghostly and shortly after she unfreezes
also chooses to abdicate the throne
making Anna the queen of arendelle
honest edit herself there are two sides
to every Bridge and their mother had two
daughters so is on on the living side of
the bridge while Elsa is on the spirit
side anything is possible but believe it
or not there is a perk to Elsa living on
in spirit form Olaf will live forever
there wasn't a dry eye in the theatre
when Anna gave Olaf his last warm hug
but what was even more devastating was
realizing that Olaf could not exist
without Elsa
but now that Elsa is a spirit she can
live on forever so that means that Olaf
will live forever - no no no don't you
that you don't know what I stepped it we
loved how frozen - ended
Anna will make one fantastic Queen and
Kristoff will make King Agner proud what
did you think about the sequel do you
believe in the Elsa is this spirit
theory or do you think she came back to
life when she unfroze sound off in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
if you like warm hugs thanks for
watching see you next time